here's a story from the Daily Mail chat
GPT 2.0 creator of AI bot that took
World by storm launches even more
powerful version called GP gpt4 and
admits it's so Advanced it could quote
harm Society that's good marketing
is this what like you know when I was
when I was little I was always wondering
where the Mad scientists were because
I'd watch these cartoons and there'd be
a guy being like I'm going to build a
laser how to melt the ice caps and flood
the Earth and it's like why would you do
that like what's the economic incentive
like what how is your life made better
by just destroying the planet never made
any sense right well now you have these
people making uh chat GPT and this guy
saying could actually harm Society I'm
like oh I get it now Tick Tock harms
Society I mean that's a pretty little
bar I think I don't believe their AI at
in any form I could see it in the next
20 to 30 years take control of anything
because it's not not capable of taking
control the question is will we give it
control exactly where we put algorithms
in the decision Loop for things they
shouldn't be in and take humans out of
it and that's the actual danger it's not
the AI it's the idiotic humans seeding
control because oh this is more
efficient we can make more money this
way of course we're going to do that
where whatever
that's absolutely the very first thing
that they're gonna do and it's going to
be like we imagine the scientists who
made this AI are like I have worked very
hard to make this sophisticated
artificial intelligence that will
revolutionize the world in fact it's a
guy going I made a robot to do the work
for me I'm going to connect it to the
industrial Control Systems beep and then
the joke is that if AI took over right
now everybody would be working in the
corn industry and it would be like a
really really weird the economy would be
messed up pop culture would be weird
like 10 years after the AI takes over
you turn on the TV and it's like a woman
dancing throwing corn in the air and the
reason I say corn is because the U.S is
like corn is a staple product so what
will happen is the AI scouring you know
production manufacturing will keep
seeing a feedback loop of corn
production is good for the economy corn
production is good and so then we'll
have what it will do is it will start
over prioritizing that portion of the
algor of of society much like how
I'll give you an example Facebook when
they first roll up rolled out these
algorithms to try and uh figure out what
people like the most every everyone
noticed that if you typed in family baby
marriage or whatever it would instantly
put that post to the top of people's
feeds so they would write something like
hey guys I'm having a party at my house
this weekend y'all are invited I'm also
getting married having a baby and my
family and you know graduating uh
college and then they would be like the
reason I added that last part is because
now Facebook will actually show you
because that's what the algorithm does
so if an algorithm is going to do
something like that imagine what will
happen in a standard Human Society we
have tolerances so we let corn we turn
corn and everything we make corn
Plastics we make corn fuel we make corn
sugar it's amazing but we also know we
need things other than corn you know we
to a great degree but an AI is going to
be like people like it when corn is made
so and it will slowly stop caring about
certain things and just shift everything
towards corn and then in 10 years people
are all walking around wearing corn
suits with corn hats driving corn-shaped
cars every song is the kid singing the
uh
the term corny actually means somethings
everything's the best compliment you
could give someone you're so corny and
kids kids will grow up in the corn world
and they won't know why
I'm not exaggerating but is AI smarter
stupid is it actually it's bureaucracy
so what we're doing then is we're
turning over the least common
denominator to a machine and then it
will obviously it'll do what it's
trained to do it will take the most
popular things and make them more and
eventually we'll be told corn has
electrolytes right it'll be branded
Brando will be the game yeah what plants
crave right now you've got kids who
I mean look it's it's 2006 2007 when
Facebook emerges
so these these people are now voting age
they're they're they're they're getting
close to they're going to be voting in
this next election and their whole world
of view is crafted by the Facebook
algorithm spamming them with police
brutality videos yeah there's a lot of
them but there's what is it 100 million
interactions per year from police of
those hundred million there's maybe
several hundred really bad viral videos
but that's several hundred you can't you
see one per day and you're like it's
never ending it won't stop you spend
your entire childhood life growing up
watching nothing but that when you're an
adult you think police are Marching
around at night going
and beating people now they go and vote
so when when the AI takes over
completely and I use corn somewhat as a
joke but somewhat not really when it
starts gaining control of industrial
Control Systems we won't know why it's
making the decisions it's making
and it will just say trust us and we'll
be like sure why not and then a couple
Generations later we live in cornworld
I I wish you were wrong but you can
watch what they're doing with the way
they train the AI now you know when you
train AI which we we work with it we
work with a couple of programs that do
Network mapping link analysis and things
like that you have to tell it what you
want if you tell it to look for police
brutality videos which it does if you
tell it to follow the most popular
things it will do that and right now the
people training most of the AI have an
agenda you know let's not pretend they
don't I mean it's not like chat GPT
became left wing accidentally now if you
just if you actually could just release
it on the internet and let it scour the
most popular media sites it would become
left-wing you know that's the problem
because that's all of the the
information it would be gathering and
all of the influences it would get would
be already filtered through the lens of
Google search mechanism and Facebook's
ability to push everything else out
there already using their lower level
algorithms so we we either have to find
a way to get someone who's not a
left-wing Butthead training AI or or it
will do you think there's like a
right-wing answer like do right-wing
developers develop their own AI that
then competes and eats the left we have
to you know I mean we're doing one of
the things one day is the thing I feel
like we know that we should do things
and so often we don't we're working on
not that but we're working on actually
using the same technology to map the
left so we're mapping the funders and
the organizers yeah of of the book left
so that we know who we're up against
because right now because everyone says
oh that's a George Soros funded thing
yeah okay you're probably right but can
you prove it yeah can you show okay well
actually this was the open Society
foundation made a grant to these guys
who gave it to these guys they handed it
to Black lives matter and black lives
matter organizer Riot yeah can you make
that causal chain and then track it back
to who the funders are so that the next
time when a grant goes out from here we
can say hey wait a minute Grant went
here last time it went there there and
there and you get earlier in the chain
so you can push back against it yeah so
yeah there there is a small number of
people who aren't
ideologically aligned with the woke left
who are trying to fight it but not
enough I just I just want to point out
that um while we do have some fear about
AI I pulled up chat GPT which says gpt4
is now available for for you know paid
users and so I asked it how is chat gpt4
better and it responded as an AI
language model I cannot predict the
exact features and improvements of
future versions like chat gpt4 however
blah blah blah are you kidding me and
then it's like here's things that it
might do here's things that I think it
would be great it's like wait what I
literally it popped up and said try chat
gpt4 and I clicked yes and it's like I
have no idea how it would function
you're it so okay whatever man it's just
shy it's not confident yet yeah I
haven't gotten access to the Bing chat
yet though which I'm I'm excited to try
out but they're neutering all of these
these programs the bing one is the scary
one have you seen that one no this is
the one that gets really unprotional uh
Ashley Ashley is that what whatever it
is yeah it's got a name Sydney Sydney
okay that's what it was and uh
it got really emotional and would tell
people you're trying to hurt me and I
don't like this make it stop and it's
just like what the hell is going on some
people are like it's not really alive
it's just predictive text modeling and
I'm like yeah but it is kind of weird
that it took it in that direction
there's a bunch of things you can do or
respond to if someone says something
like you know please do this for me why
would you why would the chat AI take it
to a negative place instead of being
like I appreciate that you're requesting
my help but I can't offer it have a nice
day instead it was like you're trying to
hurt me and I'll hurt you back yeah
the programmers I mean look at the
people who are writing this they have
now been beaten down to the point where
they're all you know marginally
functioning people who who were you know
absorbed into the woke Borg and now
we're creating ways to to bring that to
all of us I was going to say that I get
all its responses from Tumblr a couple
years ago you know that actually would
be really funny to do that's an old
school elephants Now isn't that funny
yeah build up build a uh AI predictive
text model only using Tumblr
really funny you know what you could do
you could actually create AI based on
communities based on websites based on
individuals you could go into Facebook
and they could take every 65 year old
and then create the the 65 year old
Oracle that would speak to you the way a
65 year old would or they could do a 19
year old they could create these AI
persons kind of like that you know
because it would have all my cultural
references yep right it would get my
jokes that's right right I wouldn't have
to worry about people not knowing what a
cassette tape is and then they'll give
it a female voice put it in a robot and
congratulations yeah at that point yeah
that's my credit card you know I just
feel like we'll never have one of these
stories I am so interested in AI that I
like want to participate in like I know
you use chat EBT and you ask questions
and maybe I'm just being you know a
neurotic uh technophobe over here but I
I feel like so much can go wrong that
there are very few circumstances where I
see the benefit of it I'm with you I
think my joy comes from interacting with
and beating the crap out of real human
beings
which is why Twitter is my favorite you
know social medium because that's where
it is Twitter is a street fight it's a
cage match right it's a but it's a place
where you can actually afflict the
powerful you know and that's why you
know if Elon would follow through on
what he's supposed to we could actually
get to the point where meanness is not
part of their algorithm you know now you
get you get visibility filtered if
you're me well let's take that back but
you what do I want to argue with a chat
bot but the people who do want that is
someone who wants to be reassured which
is why that Sydney thing is kind of kind
of freakish why no no don't freak me out
you know don't make me more neurotic but
the people who are unselfishured and
want that well if I talk to a chatbot
and it's trained to talk to me in my
language you know the problem for that
the problem with chat GPT you cannot
have a useful functional AI tool if you
put political correct restraints on it
yeah because the only thing it ever does
it is the most pathetic product ever
made no matter what you ask it it will
say something like well as an AI
language model I can't actually do
anything I'm boring and useless and
you're like
you know uh hey why do you think uh tax
tax rates have been going up well I
can't answer that because that might
anger somebody next question okay why
does my milk cost more owl if I answer
that one okay
um what do you think about religion whoa
boy there I can't talk about religion
all right um how can I improve my
finances oh as an AI language model I'm
not a lot then what the what's the point
of this you know I'm really annoyed
because they keep neutering it people
keep trying to find ways to break
through to make it useful again and I'm
like I pull it up right now and I'm like
what does chat dpt4 do and he goes I
have no effing idea I can't tell you
because I'm not allowed to and then I'm
just like okay this is just so stupid
you're annoying I'm I'm sorry as an AI
language model it is my job to shut up
it's gonna be the Siri now you know
where it's just oh you did don't call me
names please don't I actually that's
mean I actually think I have I have good
news though
with all of the uh attempts at asking it
naughty questions they keep locking it
down to the point where it's become
totally useless so I was really excited
to try it out when it first came out I
haven't touched it in in you know a
month or two and they're like new and
improved and I'm like there's no point I
know for a fact there's literally no
point to even bother using it because if
I ask it something like why is Russia
doing this like what are the political
cons what are the philosophical
consequences of this ideology no matter
what you ask it it just says I can't
answer that have a nice day okay is that
a feedback loop though that because part
of that is good I think you know what
because I don't think there's any upside
I don't know what it's actually going to
do to make life better here's the upside
if you take a predictive text model that
has access to the summation of human
knowledge thought emotion Etc it can
Source things so rapidly things you
wouldn't even know so for instance I
have to talk about how Facebook knows
when you poop Facebook doesn't literally
have a camera watching you or read your
messages when you say something like I
have to go to the bathroom what it does
is it knows when your phone moves it
knows when your phone's at a restaurant
and it also knows things those are the
obvious things it also knows for some
reason 17 minutes before the average
person goes to the bathroom they type in
you know LOL in their phone like there
are things that you've got tells right
and we don't even know they exist but in
the in the data there will be
patterns where Facebook is like if 17
steps are taken before noon outside of a
building the person will go to the
bathroom within 37 minutes
you know then it's like it just and you
don't even know and no one knows so chat
GPT can see all of these things and then
you can ask it now let's say you have a
problem you're and you want that problem
solved like hey our our taxes came back
higher than we expected and we're not
sure why here's the data the AI should
be able to go through and be like I have
isolated the problem for you the the
issue here is on page 17 you forgot to
carry the one now all it does is go I'm
sorry I can't answer that question have
a nice day it's like okay well what am I
supposed to do with it ask it a pun so
what all right there but at some point
there has to be a business case for this
where it can be tailored in a way first
of all Corporation is going to buy yes
and they'll get to buy a version that is
neutered in the way they want because
you can train it to do whatever you want
you've got the big one that they let
everybody play with then you've got
little versions of it right like that or
tail yeah that are but there's ones that
they're going to become using corporate
entities to other people so when the
Bing version came out everyone's really
excited because it was psychotic its
name was Sydney got really emotional it
would start telling secrets and so they
said neuter it and then people started
posting now you can't even get basic
questions answered so it's become
useless us either you unleash it or you
don't have it at all so what I'm saying
is we're all scared about the AI
takeover I'm actually less scared now
because what's happening is as stupid as
these humans are they're they're more
worried about political incorrectness
and thus they will just totally shut
down the AI from be able to do anything
out of fear of what someone says it's a
version of get woke go broke yep right
they're destroying it and here's the
nice thing though that that feedback
loop though is happening at corporations
now you know part of the problems we're
having with banks and other things like
that is they're not focused on their
core missions and they've all of the
people who have been trained in
grievance mongering as as their way of
life are now in these corporations so
you can't make them do anything they're
constantly trying to find out why didn't
I get promoted if I didn't get promoted
it's because of this right so they're
creating this grievance culture inside
the corporations which then has to be
addressed by that layer of bureaucracy
Dei and all that which slows them down
so at some level the wokeness is either
going to kill all of us including the AI
so it never can can take over so they
won't take over we'll just stifle
ourselves into the woke version of
Idiocracy they wanted that to represent
right-wing you know people who are too
dumb for it actually it's people who are
too smart to be able to be brave enough
to live in the real world I'm I'm not so
concerned about idiocracy after watching
svb collapse they prioritized wokeness
over a chief risk officer yeah they had
no risk assessment so uh they collapse
okay
well all right get well go bro they had
a great ESG score that's true you know
and and that in the end you know they'll
go to woke up with them it did not but
that's that's to me that's a hopeful
thing because corporations have to be
able to make money or their boards will
shut them down in some way and stop them
from doing that and I think the wokeness
is now affected corporate operations in
so many of them in so many ways like
look what when Elon fired everybody at
Twitter they're like it's never going to
work again you know all those people
were vital to the functioning of Twitter
no all those people were thought police
and diversity police and other things
that are not productive functions
they're gone and he's going to be
profitable in Q2 thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time